ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويد
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي لواء فايز
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني يقول ان قواته ما
زالت في المرحله التمهيديه ما هي الخلاصات
التي يمكن استنتاجها من هذه المرحله
واستخدام هذه الخلاصات لتحديد ماهيه
الهجوم المضاد
يعني كثر الحديث حول منذ تقريبا شهر بدائل
هجوم في الرابع من الشهر هل هو الهجوم
المضاد هل هي المرحله التمهيديه
وتحدثنا كثيرا
وقلت ان هذه هي تمثل المرحله التمهيديه
لجمله اسباب ولديها العديد من المهام
المحدده اهم الاسباب ان حجم القوه التي
اشترك في العمليات العسكريه
لا يتجاوز في الحد الادنى 30% من حجم
القوه المخصصه اي ثلاثه الويه من اصل تسعه
او خمس القوه بقياسا الى مركز دراسات
الحرب الذي قال بانه يوجد لدى اوكرانيا من
تسعه الى 15 لواء المهام بصوره عامه كانت
هي اولا
عمليات جسر النبض استطلاع بالقوه تحديد
نقاط الضعف في الدفاعات
الروسيه هذه العمليه التمهيديه لوقفايز هل
تعطينا اي مؤشرات على شكل وطبيعه الهجوم
المضاده والاهداف اهداف هذا الهجوم من اين
سيبدا هذا الهجوم ابرز محاور هذا الهجوم
الان تعطي اشارات لكن لا يمكن اخذها
بالمطلق بانها اشارات دقيقه قد تكون ضمن
اطار عما يطلق عليه عمليه الخداع
الاستراتيجي وكيف ذلك اولا هذه الاختراقات
التي حدثت في ثلاثه مناطق في جبروجيا في
دونيسك
واخر شيء في خرسون عند عمليه عبور نهر
دنيفرو وبالتالي اي نجاحات يمكن تطويرها
اي بمعنى اخر اذا ما نجحت في تطويق
اذا استعاده السيطره عليها ووصلت الى نهر
بخموتيسكى الان ستصبح هي جهد رئيس اذا ما
نجحت في منطقه ذابروجيا ووصلت الى توكمك
ستكون هناك بديل اخر ولكن الاخطر من
المقاربتين
لم يتم بحثه حتى هذه اللحظه منطقه
جبالوجيا انا في قراءه المبدئيه للخارطه
اقول ان هذه النجاحات يمكن تطويرها وفي
حال واجهت عقبات سيفاجئ الجميع ان الجهد
الرئيسي لن ياتي من هذه المناطق سياتي من
خرس خاصه بعد تدمير السد لماذا لان حجم
الدفاعات الروسيه قليل تم نقل جزء كبير من
هذه القوه بعد بعد تدمير السد وتم نقل
باتجاه
اصبحت خاسره رخوه تعتبر اقصر المقتربات
التي تقود الى عمق الزجاجه مدخل شبه جزيره
القرم اذا اذا نجحت الخيارات في
دونيس او فيزا بروجيا توك ماك قد تحول الى
جهد رئيسي اذا تعثرت سيكون الاحتياط
الاستراتيجي جاهزا للاندفاع بمناوره
التفاف عميقه من منطقه خرسون باتجاه شبه
جزيره عندما يقول وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
ان الجيش الاوكراني في توضيح التحضير وان
كل جبهه ستكون لها مناوراتها الخاصه
بالمفهوم العسكري ما الذي يعنيه هذا
مناورات خاصه لكل جبهه
لماذا لانه هذه هي
المناوره تعتمد على طبيعه
التوظيف الدفاعي للقوات الروسيه الان اذا
ذهبنا شمالا الى منطقه
التي تهاجم القوات الروسيه التي تدافع
القوات الاوكرانيه اذا ما نجحت باحتواء
الهجوم ستتحول للتعرف سيتم اتساع الجبهه
وستشكل خطوره في عمليه اختراق عميق
وانتفاف باتجاهي
اذا ذهبنا الى باكموت كما قلت لك اذا ما
تم السيطره على ومن ثم سوليدار ستنفتح
الارض بسبب السيطره على شبكات الطرق وطرق
الشريعه وبالتالي يتحول اتجاه المناوره
كذلك في منطقه خرسون
في منطقه اذا وصلوا الى توكمت هذه ستكون
بيضه القبان في العمليات العسكريه شكرا لك
كنت معنا من عمان